hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to been in it I feel in
better fashion than I did before that
doesn't mean that I'm any more
fashionable that just means I feel
better what are you going to do slice
and fall is the name of the game fun why
don't you start it off by calling it
slice oh that's why okay well tits ah
yes I made it in one piece shockingly
where am I supposed to fall next oh this
is stupid oh this is stupid
Oh what the heck
all right here we go here we go baby
land on it yes I did it I think and I
got a golden idol of my Baba I love when
I get the golden idol amoun Baba because
that means that I'm actually good at
what I do
not really oh I'm not gonna make this
one yeah man I think I was close but I'm
not exactly sure what happened to me I
kind of disappeared into a pit of
despair Oh frak frak my luck okay oh
that's a pit of spikes what an apt name
for the pit of despair in my opinion ow
I probably broke all my bones in my body
not that that matters because I am the
undead miss huh okay I thought I thought
you were going to be the dude to me all
right we're just gonna do not ugly oh
okay then never mind we're fine yep okay
all right
everything's okay do I really want those
yeah because I need them to unlock
levels methinks hm
yeah little victory twerk here oh that's
not at work what is that
okay I didn't even know those were
options I thought I just know oh why no
why no why did I push that button Oh
what heartbreak Oh what horrendous
heartbreak why did I bounce an extra
time there I don't know I don't know ah
oh [ __ ] why can't I get on here now what
am I doing wrong now what's going on now
huh dig there we go oh I made a crack
right in the wall they're probably on a
take blame for that one ow
landed right on my neck right on the
cushy soft part of my neck oh god damn
it what have I done now can you not
twerk for one damn second it's like
you're obsessed with it it's a problem
now it's not even in fashion anymore
stop just just stop dude I think some
progress is being made here I think I
think maybe maybe maybe there we go I
made it [ __ ] [ __ ] alright there we go
wow it's fun glad that was a nice little
detour to everything that we were
supposed to be doing ow again how do I
keep doing this
hey we finally freaking made it it's
about frickin time we frickin did it
Frick Frick Frick yes mmm so sad you
succeeded Oh
there wouldn't be a TV show oh no no no
you will die okay here we go all right
let's do this it's the stupidest jumps
that get me it's it's not anything
complicated in the game I can dodge
anything it throws at me hey don't bring
up evidence of me not dodging everything
it throws at me because I can do that
aah it's the simple gaps and jumps that
I don't see that are the problem like
that one there L is almost a problem
where are we going now what hellhole are
you delivery oh god I can see it I can
see the hole of hell oh I can see it all
oh you [ __ ] oh you [ __ ] bow you [ __ ]
now is the biggest dick move of any dick
move I've ever seen in my life Oh
goodbye no I'll wait oh don't worry
about me I'll be right here enjoying the
environment I have my water
hmm I love it when it splashes me back
in the face cuz I'm in a hurry
dude such dick move God dingus dang it
what a douche what a douche
everyone comment about how douchey that
move was my good okay I'm over it now
what what
what why is this oh I was confused I was
very confused okay that makes more sense
okay got it Oh got it
okay where am I going with this oh okay
all right
I'm okay I'm okay all right where am I
go with this okay this seems like bad ow
get up get up get up get up get up good
oh where was it oh okay I thought it was
passing by directly over poop oh that's
not a good time
whoop oh and hook Oh can't believe I got
that okay whoo here we go
[ __ ] oh god damn it get back on the body
on the body on the buddy huh
aah aah maybe I can just jump all the
way through I think I can do that I
think I can navigate it no can angulate
nope nope can't do that I can do this I
can do this I believe in myself and
that's all that matters Oh going fast
almost made it though
Oh almost made it almost be there no
control if I hit something yes yes yes I
totally cheated the system and I love it
oh it developers eat it oh oh okay
when are you gonna come back hmm why do
I get to do this in sequence with
everything else I've already done huh
that seems rather do she did you're not
gonna get me I'm too quick for you nice
lie like Fox owe me boned
oh [ __ ] yes I'm still alive I don't even
need to reassemble holy titties this by
the way this level wolf this level is
huh this level is no joke this level is
everything that my nightmares are made
of
okay I should have known by the name of
the level that it was gonna be something
terrible you don't [ __ ] up here
another one another one I don't know
another one oh it's hard enough as it
was but I did it and that's all that
matters so I'll do another one
edie fillet I don't like the sound of
that
how many honey uh how many of these have
I missed I've missed a lot in these
stages I'll do the bonus one so that I
can get some canned meat and then in the
off-camera I'll go back through them for
some weird reason oh I'll do it later
okay
box fun I'm gonna be having [ __ ] this
level
did you guys hear it's gonna be fun
actually it doesn't seem so bad right
off the bat seems pretty cool okay I can
dig it I'm down with it
this seems cool oh no he's having fun oh
god what is that in the distance holy
[ __ ] Oh God
what are those things horrifying moons
like who is the set developer on the
show
ah some of them you can push over Oh
some of them fall away and kill you no
okay so I gotta find whatever oh thank
you ah okay I'm down seriously who did
they hire to build this plane yeah [ __ ]
oh no all the way back at the beginning
are you kidding me
oh god do I have to go through the whole
goddamn game like this is they're not
gonna be another checkpoint anywhere in
this [ __ ] oh I got to do it every time
- oh no oh I'm boned okay all right
I didn't sound good then you guys here
box [ __ ] ah it's so fun I'm doing this
for meat doing it for meat I need the
meat for some reason even though they
sound empty and I'm probably not
actually getting anything out of them
but hey at least there's a checker point
I like a checker point yeah mate tasty
oh that's candy me oh oh oh no no no oh
oh oh oh god oh god oh god
thank you I appreciate that you gave me
an opportunity to fall and I took it you
didn't give me that when I just took it
anyway I'm getting a little greedy on my
own destruction
god I don't like to look at that one
hello buddy
hello okay so this one already is gonna
fall oh oh I shouldn't oppress that oh I
needed to go to the other side of that
that's the opposite of what I needed
Oh No Oh is the button I thought I
should made it I'm the best I'm the best
look at me I'm the greatest okay even
though I shouldn't have done that I'm
gonna claim like it was supposed to be
done it was just an effort to show my
skill oh this is so fun
Rick you Frick you Frick you Paul Frick
you baby Frick you forget check one I
like the sound of that
can I please thank you and yes and off
we go okay so far so good
horrible moons aside everything is going
hunky-dory for me and I'm loving life
even though I'm dead I need to reiterate
that I'm very dead everything I do is
about me being dead oh thank you I need
that all right up is that me oh this
checkpoint over there
OOP thank you that was very important
actually if I hadn't gotten that I would
have been boned forever and ever and
ever and ever and ever and ever and ever
even though I've reiterated many times
throughout this episode I am bowing
forever
you okay huh you can't hide for me
give me your me yes delicious me okay
where does that go
yep okay so far so good that I can't get
up there but I can go around
oh don't know what I was jumping on but
it was something gonna make it gonna
make it gonna make it good I don't know
where this going I don't know where this
is going I don't know where this going
but I hope it's gonna be good
they better be some bonus community [ __ ]
Oh God like seriously I don't want to be
that guy and criticize video game logic
here but I'm gonna be that guy and I'm
gonna criticize video game logic here
how in the hell [ __ ] how in the hell am
I supposed to do I aim for you go come
on I missed goodbye sir how about
another one about another one let me
give you another face full this year
nightmare monstrosity take it from a
higher angle baby oh [ __ ] I'm gonna get
you I'm gonna get you eventually you're
gonna see what's gonna happen when I go
down your gullet that sounded oddly
sexual but it's not it was anything but
sexual and ah right in your mouth [ __ ]
I didn't get anything for that but it
makes me feel good I don't know why I'm
doing it either I think I'm losing my
goddamn mind you you want some you want
some of this - bang I missed thing that
gonna get you we ah missed how about you
you want a face full of this bang oh my
neck is woke alright then I guess we're
just going over here bang
okay what was it porn to that I I have a
feeling I was supposed to do something
else about that because that seemed like
a counterintuitive way to go about doing
nothing and I missed some cams why did I
go there
oh maybe to bypass all the [ __ ] maybe it
was that was all it was it was it was
just a shortcut make my life a little
bit easier which I do appreciate
I really do ah thank you only a few more
left I must be good ass I think that's
gold over there
ah tits hello I secret ah oh oh oh oh no
that was not a good idea okay
so I got to be a little bit quicker
about that but there is something over
there
something secret whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
I goddamn it well [ __ ] oh come on man
because some of it is like it's like
sticky directional like the way you jump
it is often just the way you face and
you'll jump forward that way as opposed
to going the way that you want to go so
if you're facing the wrong direction
when you make the jumping it tosses you
in a different way I've now eaten up
about 15 minutes trying this [ __ ]
and I'm not gonna stop until I get it
but I just wanted to comment about how
much time I'm wasting dicks [ __ ] jump
when you jump
oh come on that's uh
oh why would you jump that way why why I
was pointed the other way why would you
randomly choose to jump off into the
abyss
[ __ ]
I do
oh and play this particular area for 30
minutes now
oh why why do you go in a [ __ ] wrong
direction
Oh God
that was it oh no what the [ __ ] no god
damn it [ __ ] Oh
hit the wrong button [ __ ] oh come on
please I'm begging you just cooperate
with me
it's
oh I can't do it I can't [ __ ] do it
okay
[ __ ] criminy Jesus Christ oh [ __ ]
I've been doing this for two and a half
hours ah I bet I'm really good at it now
I bet I'm really really unbelievably
good at this game which is really really
weird and I'm gonna see how that plays
out by me trying to get through this
area well look at this it's a bunch of
[ __ ] I still fail at it my god I
cannot explain to you how aggravate
aggravating beyond aggravating that is
that was the whole section
he's just set up for failure because
I'll explain why if it wasn't clear in
my inane ramblings and assorted
screaming's
why that was god damn it why it was
awful and I'll do it as soon as I get
past this [ __ ] part cuz I can do this
[ __ ] what good god damn it of course
my fingers are so set up for that one
run that I can't do simple [ __ ] now oh
man
why are you flinging me forward oh my
god you've gotta be joking me okay Wow
I cannot explain to you guys how
aggravating that was words cannot
describe the kind of literal physical
pain that I went through to try to
accomplish that it was unreal how
sporadic and different it was every time
the combination of the lighting and the
physics of it and timing the jumps it
was so different every time I was so
good at it and yet I was so bad and I
was so close so many times I was right
there and arguably on that one attempt
when I hit the wrong button because my
body is like drained I got trained to
the point where if I was you thought I
was gonna fail I just hit it anyway
instinctively
and I think I could have made it because
of the weird way the physics is set up
oh my god it was so painful I can't
describe the pain and the reward you
want to know what the reward was for all
of that [ __ ] it's some creepypasta
been drowned [ __ ] it's aggravating
how up their own ass the developer is to
think that I would care that I would
even remotely care about your mspaint
[ __ ] drawing oh my god it's so
creepy that's so stupid it's so stupid
I'm sorry it's stupid for the pain that
you made me go through and I didn't even
get to the end of it I was there like
five times and I couldn't finish aah
I have never been through so much pain
playing a game even playing the twenty
twenty twenty modes for five nights at
freddys was not as aggravating as that
and I I literally couldn't do it I
physically couldn't do it I physically
could not do it because five nights at
freddys way mode might have been random
this was random to the most infuriating
degree in that your controls were not
precise so [ __ ] that I'm gonna go on
with my life and enjoy sunshine and
rainbows and something to give me joy
because I have no joy left in my soul I
have nothing I have nothing yeah yeah
yeah yeah so thank you everybody so much
for watching I appreciate you guys
sticking with me and thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye I am dead inside
why is it a vertical table set a thing
where you just hold your hands up and
you just let it in you that's the way I
like it